SPEAKER 1: Man is unlike
anything else in creation.
He sits there with these divine
qualities and simultaneously
these very earthly qualities.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're told in
Genesis, chapter 1:26
that God has made
man in his image
and by his likeness
has he made him.
And this is a really
important distinction,
because man is unlike
anything else in creation.
He sits there with these divine
qualities and simultaneously
these very earthly qualities.
And it's the tension
between the two,
the tension between the earthly
and the divine, that comes to--
it comes to define
man's interaction
with other humans and the
divine throughout the book.
In Genesis, chapter 2,
verse 5, "On the day
the Lord God made
Earth and heavens,
no shrub of the field being
yet on the Earth and no plant
of the field yet sprouted,
for the Lord God had not
caused rain to
fall on the Earth,
and there was no human
to till the soil,
and wetness would
well from the Earth
to water all the
surface of the soil.
Then God fashioned the
human, humus from soil,
and blew into his nostrils
the breath of life,
and the human became
a living creature."
This is Robert Alter's
translation of Genesis,
and he's trying to--
he's trying to depict
for us in English
the wordplay that's
there in Hebrew.
"Adam" just means
"the human being."
And the human being,
the wordplay there,
it was taken from "Adama,"
which means "from the soil."
God's taking this human
being from the soil.
But note, he is into the
human, once God blows
into his nostrils.
You see the breath of God.
You see something of the divine
coming down to the human.
It's really a thing of beauty.
You see this kind of
majestic creature,
unlike the other ones thus far.
And I think the most
startling statement
in the entirety of
these opening chapters,
of the first three
chapters of Genesis
comes now here in verse 18.
"And the Lord God
said, 'It is not
good for the human to be alone.
I shall make him a sustainer
beside him.'" For the first
time, if you go back to Genesis
chapter 1, God repeatedly says,
"And it was good," "and it
was good," "and it was good."
Every act of creation is good.
All things are good
in this narrative.
But now we are going to get
a key insight with regards
to the human and really
what it means to be a human.
Because for the first
time, we are told
that something is not good.
And it is not good
that man is alone.
This comes to help us understand
that we aren't these autonomous
beings, answerable to no one.
We would like to say we're
only answerable to God.
But even here, we
understand there
is something about what it
means to be the human here,
that being in isolation
is wholly unacceptable.
And so what does God do?
He starts fashioning animals.
"The Lord fashioned
from the soil
each beast of the field and
each fowl of the heavens
and brought each to the human
to see what he would call it.
Whatever the human
called a living creature,
that was its name."
But of course, we're
told after all of this,
there was no sustainer found
for the human in these animals.
Verse 21, "And the Lord God cast
a deep slumber on the human,
and he slept.
And He took one of his ribs
and closed over the flesh
where it had been.
And the Lord God built the rib
he had taken from the human
into a woman, and He
brought her to the human.
And the human said,
'This one at last,
bone of my bones and
flesh of my flesh,
this one shall be called Woman,
for from man was this one
taken.'"
It's this beautiful moment,
because what we see here
with regards to humankind's
notion of personhood
is that it's a
corporate personhood,
is that to understand what
it means to be a human person
isn't simply to be a unique
individual surrounded
by all of these other
unique individuals made
in the same way.
But rather, we are in
a sense incomplete.
We can't even name who we are.
We have no identity
if we are not
in a relationship to
another human person.
In fact, look at the poem
that Adam offers to us.
"This one at last, bone of my
bones and flesh of my flesh."
Notice he names
this one precisely
in the way in which he's
going to name the animals.
This one shall be called Woman--
the Hebrew, isha, also a word
that's used for wife.
This one shall be
called woman, isha.
And now notice what he does.
For from man, ish,
was this one taken.
It's a beautiful moment,
because now what you see
is in the act of naming this
other human being across
from him, only then can
he actually name himself
as a separate identity.
Because it's really not
a separate identity.
They're bound to one another.
The very notion
of personhood here
is found here in
this relationship.
From isha, only
once that's named
can I actually now have an
understanding of myself.
And so this begins to stake
out what the human-to-the-human
relationship is.
And then what we will see,
come chapter 3, is a fall,
is a disruption, is a rupture
of this human-to-human
relationship.
And it turns out the rupture
in this human-to-human
relationship, where she is
to be a sustainer to him, he
is to find his own
personhood there in isha,
what we'll find
here is it's also
a disruption in the divine
and human relationship.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlight series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.